former vice-president of officiating and
senior VP of officiating of the National
Football League
Dean Blandino good to see you sir nice
to see you let's before we get in all
this I've see on your history or NFL
officiating in turn 1994 so this is deep
into the disabled years right right in
the middle of the tag label years the
sweet spot of the tag label years uh-huh
and yeah I started as an intern and the
NFL actually called called my house we
didn't have cell phones at that point
called my house about coming in for an
interview for an internship and my mom
thought it was one of my friends playing
a joke and almost hung up so so your mom
answers the phone my mom answered the
phone was like who is this and I was
like mom give me the phone it was yeah
so I might not have been here today had
she hung up the phone so Dean the NFL's
on their own like actually happened and
actually happened it actually happened
and then what did you do as an intern I
was doing whatever they asked me to do I
was actually doing a lot of editing of
video putting together tapes and things
like that that's how I learned
officiating because I was putting
holding tapes together or pass
interference tapes together and it
wasn't digital back then so you actually
had to watch the tape while you while it
was recording so I would watch it and
that's how I learned all the officiating
who's the head of NFL refs then Jerry
seaman
Jerry seaman okay came off the field and
came off the field he his last game was
the Giants Bills Super Bowl the wide
right game and and then was the head of
officiating now here you are now Here I
am now who you are at the the
cross-section of NFL and extinction
according to those watching people the
helmet rule being applied over the first
two weeks of the preseason what are your
thoughts on what you're hearing and
seeing of what's being called deep well
you know yeah I think it's being over
officiated right now but I think that's
by design they want the officials to
throw flags and so they can get a
library together and that's no different
than other point of emphasis fouls that
we've had in the past preseason fouls
are always higher per game last five
years you have four more fouls per game
in the preseason than you do the regular
season so they do drop 51,000 33 games
roughly one and a half per game that's a
high number for specific
player safety foul but I think that that
number is going to drop they're actually
having a call today with the competition
committee which is unfortunate because
the two greatest minds in in sports
officiating are here that's correct
we're not on that call Hey look I'd love
to be on that so what what do you think
is being discussed on that call having
been through calls like this before yeah
I think I think al river on my successor
he's on that call they're talking about
all of the fouls that that have been
called some that weren't how comfortable
he feels with how the officials are
doing from a consistency standpoint I
think they're getting ready to put
together a tape that'll go out to
everyone after the preseason ends just
so they can provide more clarity as we
go into week one but I mean how is that
gonna work
I mean some of these alright let's take
it one step at a time did you when you
were the head of NFL reps prior to
preseason stay calm or calm or cuz I
need a library video we did we we were
we we would always say when in question
throw the flag because it's easier to
tell the official we don't want that
called
then then we do want to call we can
always pull it back so that happened in
20 2014 we had the the points of
emphasis with defensive holding thousand
the preseason we were throwing two and a
half files per game in the preseason for
holding that dropped to under one and a
half per game and you and then so you
again as a former NFL head of NFL reps
would then tell the guys now it's the
regular-season call that well no we
would put the tape together and we would
say here here are 10 examples of what we
want called what the competition
committee wants called here are 10
examples of what we don't want called so
we had that library to pull from and
then we could show the officials and
we're doing that throughout the
preseason and then we can show them and
hopefully regulate you know where we
want that line to be Dean Glen do you
know current NFL on Fox rules analyst
here in the Rich Eisen show so wouldn't
Mike Zimmer know that this has been done
before I mean he's been around football
forever he's saying that this is gonna
cost people jobs and the playoffs would
you disagree with no I don't have look
officiating calls are always whether
it's pass interference or the helmet
rule they're always going to impact
games this is a big change and I think
this is a culture change
with the NFL's trying to do is they're
trying to get the head out of the game
and this is a broad rule the way it's
written and and I think we're seeing a
culture change when I started in 94 one
of the first projects I worked on was a
hit on defenseless receivers tape and it
had guys like Chuck Cecil and Mark
carrier and and some of these safeties
and they were just killing people and if
you put that tape on today I don't think
there's anybody that watches football
would think that that was okay and that
was acceptable back then and then in 95
they changed the rule on defenseless
players expanded it players had to
adjust and they did and I think that's
what we're seeing now well we had Josh
Norman on yesterday and he's like just
how cuz some of these calls that we're
seeing in the preseason these players
are just bracing themselves for impact
that they're not creating and we're
seeing a flag called on the defender
that's the key that and that's the
adjustment but how is that even fine to
be called now just for the sake of
getting tape for a library that will be
put out to teams and coaches before the
season when it's freaking fans out I
think I think where the direction to the
game official isn't just throw it's if
you if you see what you think is a foul
typically you tell the official you got
to be a hundred percent sure to throw
the flag right what they tell them is
okay if you think it's a foul it's close
throw the flag that that's all this is
and and Josh's point and Richard Sherman
and these guys are thoughtful guys and
they get it but the key is the league
put out tape position-specific tapes I
don't know if you've seen him head
coaches Mike Vrabel Doug Marrone Todd
Bowles they all did a tape and what they
were saying and if you watch these tapes
its knees bent pads low head up and
that's really what they're trying to do
get the players to to keep the head up
not always possible and that's not
always bad look III told you this
backstage I'll say it here when we're
front of microphones in front of
everybody is that the Shamar Co Thomas
hit on David Moore in pre-season week
one that was flag and he was ejected for
that should be out of the game those
plays are dangerous it's gonna kill
somebody
literally and and I I think that this if
this is all working towards removing
that from the game great yeah but fans
who are seeing all the other calls that
are confusing is going to lead despite
how many tapes that are being put out
there right now with the way the rule is
written I'm concerned that after the
catch rule has now been in my mind fixed
and we'll get to that Dean Glen do you
know here in the Honda inside a report
shortly but I'm concerned that after the
catch rule is now fixed we're now gonna
be sitting here saying what's a tackle
what's not a tackle and in where is the
catch rule was just dealing with catches
which doesn't happen on every play every
play has a tackle or involves an
attempted one so oh yeah how is this
gonna work I think I think the goal is
to get that that egregious flagrant hit
out of the game and I think the
committee and the league will live with
some of these calls that maybe shouldn't
be made that's just part of the growing
pains and then but I really feel like
today on this call and the direction
they're gonna go in is they're gonna
narrow it down I think they're gonna
narrow it down make it less broad at
least how it's being applied to where
you know we talked about maybe it's more
the crown of the helmet because a lot of
the incidental contact with the helmet
is the side of the helmet versus really
lowering the head in that traditional
spearing posture so I think they're
gonna narrow it I think we're gonna see
less calls during the regular season and
and again but it is a culture change and
they're trying to get that that real
flagrant hit out of the game and so just
I guess put a button on it here Dean cuz
again I have the rule as it's written
it's a foul if a player lowers his head
to initiate and make contact with his
helmet against an opponent contact does
not have to be an opponent's head or
neck area lowering the head and
initiating contact an opponent's torso
hips and lower body also a foul so to me
I've never seen somebody try to initiate
contact and harm somebody with the side
of their helmet they're not coming in
like sort of most of the time but in
this with the side of their helmet now
so to maybe put in the language today
where they've put in language today to
say crown of helmet I do
because the side of the helmet if you
put it in crown of the helmet then some
of these tackles that we're seeing that
our look to be great form tackles side
is the helmet is to the literally side
of the body of the player that you're
trying to tackle and it's that shoulder
but side of the helmet does make contact
yeah that if we're somehow codify it to
take those out of the flaga Bowl moments
maybe we've got something they might I
don't know if they're gonna change the
actual language but the direction to the
game officials because again if you
initiate with your helmet then by
definition it's not incidental and I
think that's the hard part for the
official in real-time they can see the
player lower the head but did he
initiate with the helmet or did he
initiate with the shoulder and was the
helmet contact incidental that's kind of
where we have to get to from a
consistency standpoint all right let's
take a 60-second break come back I
believe the catch rule has been fixed
I'm wondering what you think and how
it's gonna look in 2018 and then I do
want to I'll give you heads up go
through your head the coach while you
were the head of NFL refs who was the
biggest pain in the ass I want to hear
that that's good stuff he's nodding his
head to my right correct I'm looking
straight at you Chris you know I think
his initials are both the same letter BB
really you think I don't know that's
back in 60 seconds with Dean Blanton
[Music]
all right welcome back to the Richardson
show Dean Blandino NFL on Fox rules
analyst along with Mike Ferraro who I
always you know had some moments going
back in that work with him and I felt
total access in the official review
segment that you also took over that's
right I never did one with you though
and you know I would always go back and
forth with Pereira tuck role got to get
out he goes no it take it would be it
add more gray area to it and I'm like
what's more there's there's nothing gray
about taking a football from the Saudi
or helmet and bringing it down what more
is an indication of I do not intend to
throw than by tucking a football right
so i lted it that windmill and then it
got changed I'm not gonna say on my
first year your first year charges I
pushed it across the goal line business
was that one of your first orders of
this that was one of my first orders
yeah yeah see that's why you and I get I
know I know so I can't take full credit
for you how much percentage was 13% I'll
take it
that's Kurt Warner's number I'll take it
okay so the catch rule drove me nuts
that I would hear and it we using under
your administration of like teach the
public more that that'll fix it it's the
debt rule not so much right look what
they what they did with the catch for
the competition committee is something
that exercise had been done for these
calvin johnson right right so this isn't
a new issue no I know and and and I and
we we all got it we looked at these
plays Dez Bryant Calvin Johnson the you
know the Jesse James plane everybody
thought they should have been catches
right the the to the the man and the
woman in the bar exactly to the to the I
hate to use that term but the average
fan true that's a catch right so how do
you write a rule to make that a catch
but the committee you know the committee
always thinks about on unintended
consequences it was say what you want
about the old rule and I don't think the
over was perfect but but there was a
bright line look if you were going to
the ground you got to hold on to it when
you land
I know but going to the ground for
somebody in the air
if somebody besides a Dez Bryant he
could cover an entire first down and
just with free snow no question no
question so I think what they did they
accomplished what they wanted to do
which was they made those play sketches
I'm just curious as to how it's gonna
play out now when we're debating not did
he hold on to it when he went to the
ground but did he make a football move
or did he have the opportunity to make a
football move I think that's going to be
the debate that's the gray area that's
the gray area and so we'll see I like I
like that the rule is more in line with
what people think I like yeah because
I've had to defend that rule for a long
long time and you're done you're saying
I are doing that time I'm done finished
offending that rule but I'm just
interested to see how it's gonna place
it's indefensible I'll be honest with
you the whole surviving the ground stuff
you just drive me insane which is so
part of the rule though so well
what is the harm in it I thought that's
gone no trying to selling you a bill of
goods oh here's the rule control the
ball get two feet down or another body
part make a football move whether taking
another step of reaching the ball toward
the goal line or yard marker such a
football move would not be required if
the catch were made in the end zone
agree
so we're surviving so if I go to the
ground if I dive to make a catch
yeah right I control it and I hit the
ground right and the ball comes out yeah
that's incomplete because I did not hold
on to it when I landed because that
there's no football move there so people
need to understand it's still part of
the rule that's not gonna be a fumble no
that's that's not a catch so what's the
unintended consequence here I don't
think the I think the unattended
consequence is again we didn't eliminate
the subjectivity in the rule we just
shifted it I think it's gonna be better
I think we're not gonna have much of a
conversation about it and I'm fortunate
about the helmet right no what's a
tackle not a tackle exactly man and so
the rule of that I would love to change
as well
would be the fumbling out of the end
zone gives the ball back to the defense
that basically the defense is and the
end zone is their friend that'd get the
ball back in that situation it is why
why is the rule that I think the rule
has been that way because it's consist
with other loose balls that the offense
puts into their opponent's endzone so a
punt the kickoff right an interception
so from a consistency standpoint that's
what it's always been and I think the
committee and all the discussions
they've had about that rule is they feel
like you've done a bad thing you fumbled
so there should be some penalty if you
don't recover it it shouldn't just come
back to the spot of the fumble if you
don't recover it then there should be a
penalty and it's a it's a it's a pretty
big penalty losing the football and
going to the 20 in all the discussions
that I've been a part of the committee
just they haven't felt compelled to make
a change
what's the Dean Blandino here on the
Rich Eisen show former head of NFL refs
and no NFL rules analyst on Fox what's
the one rule that you would want to
change that you couldn't push across
when you were in a position and maybe do
it or one thing right now well you know
I like where the game is I don't think
we need to change a ton of rules every
year I I really do you know there's some
things maybe in the timing of it I'd
love to I'd love to speed up replay I'd
love to make it just more efficient I
hate you know even when I was a part of
it that those reviews that take two two
and a half minutes it's it's it kills
the flow of the game we noticed last
year that when it was the first year
foul river on that they changed the way
that replay was used and catch not a
catch from snap one all the way up to
Kelvin Benjamin's catch in week 16 that
was ruled not a catch and then in the
playoffs it looked like it went back to
your way of not treating everything like
it was a Sapru der film would we stay
with the stands is called unless it's
incontrovertible evidence did you notice
that yeah no question I think I think
there in the regular season
there were times where they were overly
technical and they were they were really
just like you said analyzing the zubru
to film when it's pretty replay is not
that hard if it's if it jumps out and
it's clear and obvious then you change
it if it doesn't you stay with the call
on the field and they went back to that
after the belt the the Kelvin Benjamin
play and and and it was much better past
that point
based on your experience would that have
been a phone call that our rivers could
have been a phone
call could have been a visit from a guy
that works on the on the top floor could
have been something like that huh it's
possible that happened me you've had
those visits you have four visits mine
might involve a certain bus trip but
that's about I wasn't gonna bring up the
glaze with you here but he's he's he's
at the Nexus of everything okay the
point because I remember sometimes when
I would be doing official review with
Pereira we would have it okay we're
gonna do it Monday at this time we're
gonna do it and then we really like we
got to do it Tuesday
why because Pereira is too busy fielding
all these phone calls sure coaches and
front office members yeah he's got to do
that so then we started pushing it to
the middle a week and he got through all
of that and he had time to do it at
segments who was the one coach that was
the biggest pain in the you-know-what
when you were the head of NFL refs on
that front so the guy for me and he was
also one of my favorites was was BA
Bruce Arians he I mean wow this guy was
he the first year I was head of
officiating he called me in September
like week two and he said he was never
gonna call again he was done with
officiating two weeks later he called
following year he accused me of betting
on the game okay because of a replay
review and then not knowing the rules
yeah he was on the team bus they do they
do the the the guys that were on the bus
do a great impression of him he em EFT
me too after the game leaving the
stadium I mean leaving the stadium it
was there another game going on that you
know it was a Thursday night game okay
so he it was late on the East Coast he
just let me have it and I always just
let him go let him go let him go
and I just said you know what watch the
tape tomorrow and then call me back and
he went from a hundred miles out an hour
to zero he was like okay call you
tomorrow and they they do a great
impression of it because he's just going
crazy and he's like alright I'll call
you tomorrow and he called me the next
day and we had a good good discussion
yes he was he was the best he's best but
even though he was are the best and the
worst all at the same time yeah now you
thought it would be Belichick right yeah
what was your relationship you know I I
always enjoyed talking to bill bill
understands officiating on a level that
that not a lot of coaches at least in my
experience understood he understood that
officials make mistakes he he really
spends a lot of time with the rules we
would talk probably every Friday about
different situations they would spend a
lot of time with the team you know when
they're rookies come in they go through
a pretty comprehensive review on the
differences between the college rules
and the NFL rules so I always enjoyed
talking to Bill and he was always great
with me you were just on every Friday
during the same Glee during the season
he would call later in the week not
maybe not every Friday but most Fridays
and and we would talk about you know
things that came up or things that he
was concerned going into the into the
next game cuz we're always talking about
how the Patriots players are always
locked in situation yeah and when
there's a ball that's just loose on the
ground and most teams just walk away
from it thinking that the plays over
someone from the Patriots is going to
scoop it up in school yeah
and you see you saw that in a saw that
and now you're seeing most teams are you
know they have somebody that that
handles officiating they have like an
analytics person that studies the crews
I mean they'll break down the crews like
they break down their opponent and
they'll know this crew coming in calls
more you know offensive holds than most
crews but bill was always you know he
really focused on that and and the rules
part of it and I always appreciated that
Dean I appreciate you coming in let's do
this a little bit more regularly
absolutely California's you're getting
set along with Pereira to take on yet
another National Football League season
the NFL on Fox Thursday Night Football
is on NFL on Fox starting again tomorrow
night bucking a current are gonna have
the Eagles and the Browns on Fox kicking
off preseason week number three as we
see the further destruction of the
National Football League due to helmet
rule that I think we just fixed we just
fix we gotta jump on that call that's
right so I got thirteen percent of it
and you got what eighty seven percent of
it that's the way it works
so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience